après la razzia de titres chez les
minimes le boxing de la verrière fondé
ses espoirs de titre régional chez les
benjamins sur salies medjahed ce jeune
verrier roi met les gants depuis quatre
ans et manie l'art du contre avec
précision salim il se débrouille pas mal
il manque un peu de sérieux n'ont pas de
régularité puisqu'il vient souvent il
est pas tout le temps très appliqué un
peu importe à dire tête en l'air pour
faire ça en expression
mais voilà sinon sinon il ya du
potentiel bien sûr nos vies de gally
trop timide pendant l'assaut son chemin
s'arrêtera en demi finale dans l'autre
coin luca ferro suit les traces de son
frère ancien triple champion de france
il participe à la verrière à son premier
championnat régional surpuissant dans sa
catégorie luca et son propre ennemi dans
une discipline où le contrôle de soi est
vital pour un jeune de son âge
onze ans il fait mal et en boxe
éducative qui est sur la touche donc
avec lui ce qu'il faut c'est surtout le
le canaliser pour pas blessé et pour pas
être disqualifié parce que les
règlements en boxe éducative ils sont
très très stricte souvent plus grand que
ses adversaires il a plus d' allonge
c'est d'ailleurs le cas en finale du
tournoi le sort du combat est vite
scellé luca févre devient le nouveau
champion régional benjamins de boxe
éducative au bout des trois rounds
le coin de luca s'est vue qui frappe
j'avais peur que son adversaire du
rentre dedans en fait et je sais pas
donc c'est très bien passé pour nous en
fait
lucas on lui a fait profiter profite
faire travailler ses déplacements il a
fait un très bel assaut je suis très
content de lui